in case there was any remaining doubt
Woody Harrelson's carnage is officially
coming to the Benham burrs bad news is
hardly a surprise as the character aka
serial killer Cletus Kasady made a
mid-credits appearance in 2018 s venom
now get out of here and I will there's
gonna be carnage now the latest buzz
surrounding the Marvel Comics baddie
involves its name in the brand new title
for the upcoming second venom movie for
The Hollywood Reporter the folks at Sony
Pictures have announced that the venom
sequel will formally be released as
venom let there be carnage even as that
subtitle seems suitably silly for the
over-the-top world conjured in the
original film it's also proving divisive
just minutes after Sony made the big
announcement venom fans the world over
took to Twitter to voice their opinions
on the let there be carnage subtitle
with some showing serious slob brother
choice and others hating everything
about it unsurprisingly fans on the
hating side of things aren't being
particularly kind to the subtitle user
primate ex bluntly tweeted why do these
movies have such dumb subtitles just
name it venom 2 and be done with it
another offer her own subtitles for the
sequel user body orphanage tweeted the
title though we can't have maximum
carnage or absolute carnage
let there be carnage sounds dumb just
say venom carnage at that point others
have noted that let there be carnage
sounds more like a tagline than a title
while one Twitter user said that the
title is so dumb and another wrote that
eight quote sounds like an SNES game and
not a good one
Twitter reactions to the venom sequels
official title weren't all negative
however user Lizzie Maximoff professed
her love for the title she tweeted then
I'll let there be carnage is such a good
title I'm shaking you know it's that
kind of positivity that rejuvenates our
faith and fandoms your wolf does not so
ugly after all
I'm almost sorry to see you dead while
the hot online debate about venom twos
official title is sure to continue
burning in the coming days Sony's
announcement came with a tinge of
legitimate bad news as well the studio
confirmed that venom let there be
carnage has been delayed from its
planned October 2020 release date given
the current state in the movie biz that
news is hardly unexpected with virtually
every remaining 2020 movie being
affected by theatres closures still
there was hope that though later 2020
releases might not suffer the brunt of
social distancing mandates as
uncertainty reigns regarding when and
how to reopen the world it seems Sony
brass are trying to keep ahead of
matters and hopefully ensure venom two
will have the theatrical release they
feel it deserves as such fans will now
have to wait until June 25th 2021 the
release day previously occupied by
Warner Brothers the Batman to see
Marvel's biggest baddest symbiotes
faceoff on the big screen the move will
presumably also give director Andy
Serkis who took over from venom Helmer
ruben fleischer more time to fine-tune
the film's expectedly bloody action if
you missed out on 2018 s venom the film
follows reporter eddie brock played by a
never weirder Tom Hardy who after being
bonded with a vile alien entity becomes
an unexpected sort of protector for
Earth what game are you we the original
film was soundly dropped by critics upon
release but was embraced by audiences
who appreciated its stylish hyper
violent story to the tune of over eight
hundred and fifty million dollars in
worldwide box-office bucks those numbers
alone essentially dictate a sequel beat
Greenland Oh Sony was quick to replace
Fleischer for the follow-up likely
hoping circus could wrangle in the
insanity a bit and focus the characters
narrative given the film's just
announced subtitle one has the wonder of
circus and by extension carnage actor
Woody Harrelson haven't actually upped
the ante in that regard
until then will rest assured knowing
that Harrelson is reprising his role as
Cletus Kasady and Benham let there be
carnage his cameo in venom certainly
made it seem like he's about to
out-crazy Tom Hardy's venom performance
in ways we can't fathom and thankfully
per leaked set photos he'll apparently
be doing so without that ridiculous wig
he was sporting in venom as a reminder
venom let there be carnage is set for
release on June 25th 2020
one check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]